ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
cucina buttata oggi sono felicissimo
perché ho fatto meditazioni ho scoperto
questo video su youtube di una tizia che
mentre guidi ti può fare meditazione è
pericolosissimo ma allo stesso tempo con
qualcosa che effettivamente ti mette con
un mindset pazzesco per cui oggi che
cosa faremo capo fritti con dog per i
coreani andiamo a prepararli subito e da
tanto tempo raga che ti voglio fare
perché sono pazzeschi stanno nei manga e
io tutte le ricette che c'erano rimanga
che vincere a testa cosa poi non ci
avete mai un uomo è stata di che non
aveva questa cosa che le ricette che
stavano nei manga vede voleva rimaniamo
tipo ramsau tom è che se mangiamo a
quella polpetta deriso che poterà
mangiarlo definite e rimane qua io
vedevo i manga porno e quindi vedevo
sempre capito questo con doghe dice oh
cazzo che voglia di magna melo è una
specie di hot dog
streetfood coreano quindi partiamo
[Musica]
ingredienti ragazzi e misurazioni pesi
tutto quanto vi trovate nell'info box
perché tanto chi cazzo se lincoln sa che
ogni volta devi tornare indietro a
vederli infobox schiarite già lì bella
per poi a questo punto io mi metto
subito a lavorare alla
non è proprio un impasto un impasto è
troppo vago è quella cosa che tipo ora
metteremo poi attorno ai core dog che ci
inzuppi che ne so i gamberi e poi li
friggi
pastella
pastella katz
english
traumi a questo punto partiamo buffo e
sprechi e ne paul
dire io la calcio del futuro
io lo giuro che ragazzo ha ragione chi
non c'è un ma le fruste in questa cucina
quando voi prendete i questi poi pensate
che io poi mi faro i gargarismi non si
possa questa roba diamogli una sbattuta
veloce aggiungiamo lo zucchero non
sapevo sinceramente servissero però
aggiungiamo a questo punto del lievito
di birra a occhio perché 4 grammi non mi
raccomando arrivi niamo dovete dire così
se setina
se siete capito di roma dovete di nemo
di milano poeta ad un servo del flower
the flowers is on the floor
farina di riso aggiungiamo e poi ci
buttiamo alcun pochino di sale ragazzi a
questo punto prende l'acqua sono 100
millilitri e di vado a rendere
temperatura ambiente mezzi caldini bo
utilizzato coso
microonde amo e ho dimenticato il suo
nome per tutto quello che ho fatto nella
vita deve essere capito un po di enna
tiepida burina queste urina che siete
che mi viene allora mettiamo l'acqua
della vita sentirete che è veramente
viscido deve darvi un pochino alla
sensazione di fare del fisting
ragazzi vedete come
molto
e ciò ok come effetto quindi quello che
noi andremo a fare adesso sarà lasciare
riposare questa pastella per un'ora il
bellico liamo e ci vediamo fra mora
[Musica]
no
[Risate]
è praticamente i wurstel deve tenerli in
mano e mettere la faccia dentro l'acqua
facciamo bollire a questo punto l'acqua
perché graziana cosa devo fare
il momento aprirmi pori perché è
fondamentale
mangiare i core dog con una dopo aver
fatto comunque una pulizia del viso nel
frattempo ragazzi io faccio per una cosa
mi preparo import avanti con la
mozzarella mozzarella per pizza è quindi
mostrare la finta mi raccomando io dovrò
prendere un pochino di misura e strane
sappiate adesso
quando graziana semplifica la cucina e
il processo culinario ti giuro
mortificante io la trovo mortificante e
sgradevole gita per questo sento nei
pesi miei stand che infilava mozzarella
dentro abutere anzi no no no no dovevamo
fare dopo seguì segui con molto
interesse semplicemente
va in tv dell'odio ok ragazzi io direi
che ci possiamo possa essere felici
dopo 4 minuti ne andiamo a togliere per
garantire ok a questo punto
stuzzicadenti
inserimento ammazzato bar centro est
inseriva nei giochi a freccette a
trapanare ora andiamo a fare una cosa
che secondo me è difficilissima e
fantascienza quando l'ho vista fare cioè
la fantascienza
fantascienza
oddio mamma mia e tocca ho già capito
finirà malissimo questa riceverlo ho
avuto un bagliore dal futuro mi bagno le
mani e con cosa
carina
sentite ma intensissima quella cosa
pensi sia normale questo usate ragazzi
non funziona possibile che gli stand
degli stand e medita il vero tu con la
tua laurea in cucina presa nel reparto
dei surgelati male qui elmo finirà molto
male di questo lo sai
è normale che sia una cosa
ok allora ti dirà benissimo
ti ritrovi sempre a lavorare pietanze
falli che
ora banco preghiamo dio ragazzi perché
veramente un casino sto coso
forse bisogna mettere un altro formaggio
che lo dico tipo veramente il galbanino
comincia graziana giù a friggere ragazzi
subito subito ma non dentro ad un
richiamo a stare il selettore l'abbiamo
seguita ma non è non era così porca
miseria ma guarda guarda cosa facevano
non si non abbiamo gli strumenti per
cucinare noi in questa cucina
la presenza della ma [ __ ] afferma mi
ha dato ragione piloti il secondo sarà
un processo verrà uno spartano vai
eccolo lì mi stai innervosendo
a cucinare
monte
rosa fanno io
[Musica]
chiamatemi senso di pregare due ragazzi
in questo momento decisivo io ragazzi ve
lo dico ma questi qua
imparerò a farli veramente bene trovate
marito domani signore e signori vogliono
beh diciamo che questo qua se c'era in
dotazione noi li molto facilmente un
partner un battuta sessista con i demo
silla
e se sono stato e sono stato scorretto
abbiamo con gli ultimi tocchi ragazzi
non viene possiamo siamo d'accordo che
non viene
che brutta cosa sembra veramente un quel
giorno del mese un'alternativa per
essere comunque un minimo omosessuali la
ricetta mi sembra già abbastanza vabbè
ma è meglio no
apparente brutto ma che fai urinando su
un povero cordoba
a chi serve il cap esiste questo nega
niente
fate non farlo fallo fallo tu che mi
guardi fallo è come il sesso lana spinge
all'orale che ti spingerà anche ti
spinge allora lì che ti spinge la rete
spingendo rane che si spingevano non
riesce però a decidersi l'importante è
sempre sporco generosa ma fatelo
pagatemi su instagram e vi prego vi
prego vi prego vi prego fatelo
e assurdo un po difficile ma assurdo ci
vediamo domenica prossima ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]